guten tag willkommen zum blockbuster
nummer fünf ich habe gar nichts richtig
zu erziehen aber ich möchte unbedingt
die adventskalender daraus machen
deswegen habe ich schon mal die kamera
ausgepackt und timo das zweite türchen
des besser einschlafen
[Musik]
doch mal weg sind
warum ist er blind geworden mein haus
geschrieben
[Musik]
pakete sehen so schön also immer ganz
kaputt macht schlagen würde wenn für
euch diesen proben also sie gerade
dachte ich so aufgemacht hat dachte ich
das wäre
willkommen zum adventskalender öffnen so
gestern hatte ich ein wts aus malbuch
das was wir uns in einen schädlichen
machen machen sich leute hier ja jetzt
schon dollar
aber schon geil aber die menschen krank
gina apitz tag wünsche ich dir und er
ist out verrückten haltestelle wenn ich
ehrlich bin sich so aus wie ich mich
fühle mich ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz
ganz schrecklich komisch furchtbar nicht
gut
und bevor jetzt jemand sagt ja dann
macht doch keinen block ist einfach
nicht hoch
ich glaube dass gerade solchen gefühlen
kann man auch sehr hilfreiche videos
machen
manchmal fühlt man sich nicht gut und
das schlimmste daran ist man denkt dass
man alleine mit den gefühlen ist obwohl
man schon weiß ich ja es gibt auch
andere die sich so fühlen können aber
trotzdem mag man sich dann plötzlich
nicht mehr weil man sich halt nicht
super fühlt und ich dachte mir was
könnte man besseres machen wenn man sich
nicht super fühlt als bisschen yoga aber
ich mache so ein entspanntes yoga ich
mache so ein körper den yoga ich sollte
mal wieder
und da ist es schon wieder aber ich
sollte mal wieder kraftvolles yoga
dieser teppich übrigens ne wir kriegen
so viele komplimente das ist schon
standard teppich von ikea aber erstens
sieht der total cool aus nach sponsor
aber ikea falls mal mit mir
zusammenarbeiten möchte ist ganz große
lust wirklich ganz ganz große los clans
bewerbungsschreiben weil diese bei ikea
und wir kriegen ganz viele komplimente
für diesen teppich und ich muss auch
sagen der ist wirklich gemütlich ist so
ein teppich wo man sich auch gerne
aufsetzt und sagt ich kann hier auch mit
einem raum auf dem boden sitzt teppiche
die sind eher dekorative aber dann nicht
so gemütlich
ja ich hole meine yogamatte aus wenn ihr
fc fahne geschaut hat und kennt ihr den
wahrscheinlich auch noch in ein kleiner
morgen sowie ihr auch manchmal ein
teppich sollte schon gerade sein so und
da reden wir jetzt ein bisschen über
psychische gesundheit ist wichtig
griechische gesundheit ist sehr wichtig
und man muss auch seine psyche acht
geben und sich nicht stressen lassen das
ist furchtbar weil diese einfacher
gesagt als getan und stresst sich immer
mit allem und jederzeit deswegen ist es
wichtig so wie euer telefoniere energie
aufzuladen und meistens vergessen wir
unsere energie aufzuladen
weil in den momenten wo wir zeit haben
unsere energie aufzuladen sitzen wir am
smartphone und da passiert alles andere
als energie aufladen ich meinen sektor
videos gucken ist supermacht mega viel
spaß ich liebe tik tok habt ihr bei
jemandem mal beobachtet wie er tickt ob
videos schaut wenn nicht ihm auf der
couch baby artikel videos schaut es ist
wirklich diese 15 sekunden manchmal eine
minute und du hörst alle 15 sekunden
irgendeinen neuen sound irgendeinen
lachen irgendeinen drama irgendetwas was
lustig ist was traurig ist was dich und
du schaust die ganze zeit und dein hirn
nimmt ja auch die ganze zeit auf was es
da sieht und das sollte uns schon sorgen
machen natürlich ist tik tok dadurch
nicht gleich ganz böse und man darf auch
sagen jetzt ob ich jetzt ein buch lese
lese viel besser aber ob ich jetzt ne
stunde zocken möchte oder halt tik tok
schauen möchte das ist in ordnung aber
man darf es nicht als seine pausen
dazwischen sehen weil das ist keine
pause und ich sag das so schön und so
schlau aber ich setze das nie um nie
wenn sich das um ich bin immer der
der bis zum ende sich viel zu viel
auflegt und keine pausen macht und am
ende dann da sitzt und denkt wie kann
das wenn ich schon wieder so weit
gekommen sein wieso habe ich dann nicht
statt vorher dran gedacht meditieren zu
spazieren zu yoga zu machen einfach zu
lesen ich habe selbst ein buch lesen ist
ein bisschen besser irgendwie action
action
ich könnte meinem schlafzimmer des
schlafs kino ich habe gerade timo aber
ich kann nicht ich werde bereit sein
soll er hat sich ja auch sein feierabend
verdient aber ich kann nicht immer
schlafzimmer 27 gehen aufgeräumt wie
schlafzimmer alles so chaotisch da kommt
nicht zur ruhe
so ich brauche mein telefon ich kann
gerade gar nicht so richtig aus machen
woran es liegt dass es mir nicht gut
geht es ist glaube ich so eine mischung
aus allem
glocken ist es gar nicht so ein großer
teil also es passiert also ich zeige
euch ja viele aus meinem alltag was
passiert noch so viel mehr natürlich
hinter den kulissen was ihr euch nicht
zeige
und ja ich mal hat man dann so drei vier
situationen die einen so belasten die
müssen auch nicht dramatisch sein aber
sie kann einen belasten und dania fühlt
man sich einfach wie ein stück scheiße
manchmal ist das meer die wurst in
unseren medien yoga oder ich mache
eigentlich das yoga für anfänger ich
mache das immer wieder ich bin glaube
ich kein yoga anfänger mehr aber ich
liebe es ist perfekt es ist super
entspannt
hallo ich verlinke euch das video was
ich jetzt benutze mal in die infobox das
könnt ihr euch dann falls ihr jetzt
inspiriert seid könnt ihr euch das
natürlich auch geben mitmachen und ja
also und weil sie meine haare wirklich
wenn sie noch nicht waschen falls sie
ganz furchtbar aussehen ich will sie
aber noch nicht war schon weil sie
gerade frisch gefärbt sondern ich habe
mir das gefühl das war schon nicht so
gut ist wie die haare also falls sie mir
jetzt sagen wollen
eine allfällige spart euch einfach die
zeit die beginnende haltung des kenntnis
im knie button breit auseinander den
oberkörper flache wunder und streckt
deine arme lang nach vorne raus yoga ist
eine yoga praxis wo wir uns im loslassen
üben
[Musik]
dann stell dir vor du kannst mitglieder
ausatmung immer schwerer werden immer
mehr abgeben
und loslassen
[Musik]
glaube dir los zu lassen von der welt da
draußen
von der geschwindigkeit des alter komme
ich nun ein ende
wenn du machst kannst du auch ein junger
klotz oder 2 binder darauf sein kopfball
[Musik]
aber nur zu geschmerzt ich bügele ich
lerne noch schwerer springst du leute
[Musik]
gerade links neben mir spüre die dehnung
vor allem der linken bein rückseite und
im mittleren langsam aus
[Musik]
und dann genießen noch ein paar letzte
tiefe atemzüge in stille ganz für dich
genieße es jetzt ganz mit dir zu sein
ganz fertig namaste wie geht's euch
einige bäume auf den kopf ja also ich
kann das auf jeden fall empfehlen
ich bin ein bisschen gewissen überrascht
von timo das term ich mich in ruhe
gelassen hat das ich kenne das schon von
ihm das eine kleine nervensäge sein kann
aber jetzt hätte ich mir gewünscht dass
der einer domain frieden respektiert da
muss ich da ein beziehungs gespräch mit
ihm führen und sagen hey mit der stirn
nicht mein schöner wenn ich sagen würde
mir ging es vorher so drei von zehn geht
es mir jetzt auf jeden fall
sieben von zehn auf jeden fall hunger
bekommen und wenn ich hunger bekommen
ist es ein gutes zeichen weil wenn ich
hunger bekommen heißt es dass meine
anspannung sich gelöst hat immer wenn
ich angespannt bin und mich nicht gut
fühle
immer wenn ich keinen hunger habe heißt
es auch meistens dass ich dann
angespannt bin oder wenn ich appetitlos
bin bin ich eigentlich schon weiß jetzt
dass essenszeit aber ich habe keinen
appetit eigentlich schon so gut also ich
habe mir einen abend gemacht um mich zu
beruhigen und timo hat meint wein
gemacht und mich zu beruhigen
das keine lösung leute nicht richtig
lecker richtig lecker
[Musik]